[Musik]
mein name ist valerie niehaus und das
ist unterm radar die vergessenen
nachrichten
2021 unerträgliche zustände am berliner
flughafen ber mit bis zu vier stunden
wartezeit müssen reisende an
deutschlands angeblich modernsten
flughafen rechnen
darüber beschweren wir uns wirklich
unerträgliche zustände in den meisten
flüchtlingslagern und davon gibt es weit
mehr als den meisten menschen bewusst
ist in katerini in jordanien zum
beispiel leben mittlerweile fast 80.000
menschen 80.000 nummer als vergleich
20.000 menschen mehr und batterie wäre
in deutschland offiziell eine großstadt
die meisten bewohner von batterie sind
syrer die zuflucht suchen vor dem krieg
in ihrem heimatland und jetzt gestrandet
sind in einem lager in dem es von allem
gerade mal das nötigste gibt und
manchmal noch nicht mal das das ist umso
fataler als das fast 20 prozent der
menschen im lager jünger sind als fünf
jahre 80.000 lagerbewohner darüber lacht
man in katar ballon in bangladesch in
diesem lager leben mehr als zehnmal so
viele
850.000 menschen die meisten von ihnen
sind ruhiger also angehörige einer meist
muslimischen minderheit die meisten
dieser geflüchteten waren ursprünglich
mal zu hause in myanmar wo ihnen erst
die staatsbürgerschaft entzogen wurde um
sie anschließend vom militär zu ermorden
oder zu vertreiben schätzungen zufolge
wurden mindestens
25.000 ruhiger umgebracht und 18.000
frauen und mädchen vergewaltigt die
ringer in katar ballon leben jetzt in
einem land in dem sie selber nicht sein
wollen und das selbst nicht die
kapazitäten hat um sie dauerhaft
aufzunehmen und wünschen sich oft nichts
lieber als die rückkehr in ein
heimatland dass sie nicht mit dem tode
bedroht
ok weiter gehts regel wirrwarr in der
bundesrepublik maske hier abstand da 2g
3g 2g plus ja wir armen deutschen ist es
so ein wahnsinn denn während wir stress
mit corona haben gibt es anderswo länder
die haben stress mit corona und krieg
jemand zum beispiel fast sieben jahre
schon dauert der dortige konflikt mit
saudi arabien einem wichtigen westlichen
verbündeten als hauptakteur das schon
vor dem krieg ärmste land auf der
arabischen halbinsel liegt nach dem
jahrelangen bürgerkrieg in trümmern
daleiden zwei millionen kinder daran
dass sie gar keine schule mehr haben und
auch nichts zu essen nach angaben von
unicef sind 80 prozent der kinder auf
humanitäre hilfe angewiesen können also
von ihrem eigenen land nicht ausreichend
versorgt werden achteinhalb millionen
kinder haben keinen zugang zu sauberem
trinkwasser und 400.000 sind schwer
unterernährt viele der kinder werden
verschleppt und zum militärdienst
gezwungen mehr als 52 trainingslager
gibt es im jemen in denen kinder
indoktriniert und zu soldaten
ausgebildet werden mehr als 10.000
kinder soldaten kämpfen im jemen einen
krieg der egal wie er ausgeht das land
auf jahrzehnte hinaus zerstört haben
wird durch den krieg um gekommene
menschen bis heute mehr als
230.000
drakonische strafen für autofahrer bis
zu 100 mehr bezahlen muss künftig die
junge mutter die auf dem weg zu den
geliebten schwiegereltern die sie
nebenbei pflegt innerorts 50 km/h zu
schnell fährt verkehrswende schön gut
aber bitte nicht bezahlt mit dem blut
deutsche autoliebhaber nochmal einen
ticken schlechter dran als deutsche
autofahrer die mindestens 1500 menschen
die 2020 weltweit zum tode verurteilt
worden die meisten davon in china iran
ägypten irak und saudi arabien und
deshalb liegt die eigentliche zahl der
zu tode verurteilten wahrscheinlich
nochmal deutlich höher denn als logisch
wenn man schon gegen die menschenrechte
verstößt dann behält man das in der
regel für sich ägypten etwa hat er
allein im jahr 2009 10 1,8 millionen
besucher aus deutschland und
gleichzeitig die dritthöchste
hinrichtungs quote der welt ja deutsche
umgeben sich halt gerne mit profis
allein im jahr 2020 hat ägypten 107
menschen hingerichtet und trotzdem
weiter entwicklungshilfe bekommen allein
1,6 milliarden euro darlehen und
zuschüsse erhält ägypten von deutschland
unter anderem für den auf und ausbau von
erneuerbaren energien
wobei da ägypten e vorreiter ist statt
des elektrischen stuhls benutzt man
komplett co2 neutral den galgen schönen
abend noch